the return of charlotte hale william's
still alive and a new park westworld
season 4 episode 2 is here and once
again i'm ready to break it all down i
don't waste any of your time so let's
get right into it the episode begins in
what appears to be south america we are
reintroduced to clementine pennyfeather
who the last time we saw her was in
jakarta indonesia she and henrio working
under maeve's orders killed the dolores
copy of musashi and retrieved his
decapitated head why take his head
unless they wanted dolores pearl inside
would they destroy it or keep it for
other purposes arriving home she's
greeted by william or most likely the
evil host version of william who's been
hell-bent on tracking down maeve and her
compatriots he asks where her old master
is a reference to how mei was her boss
at the mariposa saloon in westworld
clementine isn't willing to give up this
information and is subsequently killed
however it's later implied a copy of her
is made that now works under williams
control meanwhile caleb and maeve are on
the road in search of william last
episode caleb and his daughter frankie
were almost killed by walter a host you
might have recognized from westworld
season 1. he too was under william's
control so caleb has left his wife and
daughter to take down william for good
caleb wonders why maeve has chosen to
come back now she was living in
isolation for many years why not find
someplace new to hide instead of coming
back to caleb later on in the episode
we'll find out that maeve's vision from
episode 1 in which she and caleb
infiltrate a base which housed an
earlier version of rehoboam happen
sometime between the end of season 3 and
beginning of season 4. we see a vision
of caleb injured here but we aren't sure
how he got out of this situation alive
caleb will later ask me if they're going
to talk about what happened after the
lighthouse i can't help but think
there's something more here than the two
of them just getting on with their lives
after this incident would i be crazy in
thinking that two of them may have had
some sort of romantic connection they
arrive at california senator ken
whitney's mansion we saw this place
briefly in episode one when maeve
accessed the memory of colonel brigham
maeve has the ability to control all
sorts of technology like this security
camera her ability to do this has
evolved over the past few seasons
there's no clear-cut answer as to how
she got this ability but we do know ford
had fiddled with her programming and
that she had all her attributes
increased in season 1. maeve shoots the
senator knowing that he is one of
william's hosts same goes for his wife
anastasia during the battle with the
senator and his wife maeve tries to shut
down the senator's motor functions but
it doesn't work not until much later
that is meev's reasoning for this is
that william has introduced upgrades but
something feels a bit fishy here while
interrogating the senator may finds out
that there are now
249 other such hosts out in the world he
goes on to call himself an emissary of
the new world order that sounds a bit
ominous by going into his mind maeve
sees the real senator was killed by
william for not agreeing to his
quote-unquote proposal this is likely
the approval of a new park in the state
of california the senator cannot in good
conscience approve of such a park
especially considering his wife's sister
died in the westworld massacre i'm
unsure if this character is anyone we
know we also get our first appearance of
charlotte hale this season the last we
saw her was in the post-credits scene of
season three in which she had a william
copy capture the real william a real
william who apparently is still alive
and kept in captivity we'll get to that
in a bit a particular note here is hale
wanting to keep the human version of
anastasia alive saying that she is the
perfect candidate for a new research
experiment caleb and maeve will later
discover this human version has gone
crazy in the barn and maeve says this
really interesting line and she may have
been human
she wasn't like any human i've ever seen
could hale have done something to her in
this quote-unquote experiment i can't
really show it because a lot of my
videos have been getting age restricted
recently but there's this close-up shot
of the blackest blood i've ever seen
oozing out of anastasia's head it rides
that fine line of is it real blood or
something else but before she dies
anastasia invites them to the opening
night of mozart's don giovanni because a
quote old friend is anxious for a
reunion this old friend seems to be
guiding these two along to a secret
entrance of delos's next park where when
asked for their reservation they've
already been inputted into the system as
mr and mrs morgan this is the delos
headquarters in san francisco they
actually used a duplicate shot from the
first episode of season 3 here i see you
trying to save money hbo deputy
assistant attorney general for
counter-terrorism jim navarro has
arrived from the justice department
requesting a meeting with the head of
delos however he's stonewalled by
clementine who now seems to be working
for the company the ceo here is referred
to as a he and my best guess is that
this is referring to william as ceo with
hale secretly pulling the strings
christina wakes up in the exact same
pose as last episode and also that of
season 1 suggesting once again that she
is in a loop and doesn't know it we
learn from peter's obituary an obituary
i may add does not have a date of birth
on it that he had donated all his money
to the hope center for mental health but
when christina visits this place she
discovers the peter meyer's wing has
been there for decades and is being torn
down i can see two explanations for this
one christina has been in a loop for
decades similar to the one delores had
in season one she remained the same and
kept going through these loops as
william kept coming back to the park and
kept getting older the downside to this
theory is it doesn't quite explain why
christina still has a scar from peter
when she wakes up in the morning if
decades had passed it would be
reasonable to presume this would have
been fixed theory 2 the peter that
interacted with christina in episode 1
was some sort of copy of the real peter
myers the memorial wing is dedicated
after this dead peter had simply been
going on his own loop over and over
again hence why he begs christina to
change his ending on her way to work we
see the same homeless man from last
episode talking about a noise coming
from the tower and it's singing a song
with no sound the only person who can
hear his music are him and the birds
birds we see dead outside the building
william plays golf when he's approached
by the vice president a vice president
whose campaign he bankrolled the vp
tells him there's some guy at the
justice department with wild theories
about him likely referring to jim
navarro there's also a callback to
william's daughter emily and the vp
never having attended her funeral
remember that william killed his own
daughter in westworld thinking she was a
host sent by ford to track him the vp
basically says william can't do as he
likes here not domestically at least
remember that westworld was built on an
island somewhere in the south china sea
we know that william has been buying
useless scrub land in nevada and with
caleb and maeve taking a train ride from
california through the desert this may
be where this new park is located but
the vp does not approve of william's
business venture likely because of the
massacre at westworld and william's
mental stability he did spend time at
the inner journeys recovery center in
season 3. william says his plan is
already done and all he needs to do is
flip a switch something we'll see him do
at the end of the episode we know
william doesn't like taking no for an
answer and has the vp killed and
replaced with a subservient copy this
seems to link up with what charlotte
hale later tells the real william that
she is slowly declawing humanity so that
her babies can flourish she's basically
setting the stage for some sort of
takeover william quotes hemingway's a
farewell to arms here which states the
world eventually breaks everyone and
kills those it doesn't break william
also gets three holes in one here
officially making him the worst person
to play golf against while arriving at
the completely empty opera nothing
suspicious there caleb calls his soldier
buddy carver to get his wife and
daughter out of the city at the center
of the stage is a victor talk machine
which was manufactured from 1901-1929
fitting in with the theme of this new
park they're about to enter which i
guess is a 1920s inspired prohibition
chicago the name of the town they enter
is even called temperance and chicago is
a great setting considering all the
gangsters of the era who made much of
their fortune there including al capone
the entrance leading to the train looks
similar to that found in westworld
however the walls are more black perhaps
a design choice by william on the train
caleb orders a sherry for maeve the
drink she would often order at the
mariposa saloon navarro is pissed off to
learn that the vp was satisfied with the
conversation with william of course we
know that this is now the replaced vp
under williams control i wonder if this
character will make another appearance
considering the last we see him is with
a fly going into his eye the same thing
happened to our cartel leader last
episode who then turned into one of
william's mindless slaves charlotte
tells him that she has plans for
humanity we aren't quite sure what those
are just yet but she wants her own
people to quote grow flourish and find
their own identity christina accesses
her past files and confirms she did
write that story about peter however her
boss calls and we learn he's been
tracking her however he says this only
happens when an employee accesses files
from a remote location i highly doubt
that back on the train caleb hands over
his phone to a greeter who seems to have
been programmed identically to angela
who you may remember as the westworld
host who greeted william in season one
and there are a lot of callbacks here
from the greeter offering to help put on
his clothes to even the dialogue
everything is bespoke and exactly your
size everything is bespoke and exactly
your size one difference from westworld
are the questions involving mental
health and it's very interesting that
maeve answers for caleb here in the
negative even though we know caleb has
been suffering from ptsd caleb and maeve
also sign a waiver allowing delos to
gather data from their experience in the
park in the original west world delos
was secretly collecting this data and
storing it in the forge with the end
goal of being able to recreate one's
consciousness which could then be
transferred into a host where one could
become immortal part of this data was
collected via the hats the guests would
wear upon arrival so it's interesting to
note that caleb declines wearing one
i've never really been much of a
hot guy we find that charlotte hale is
keeping what appears to be the real-life
william alive in a device that looks a
lot like the ones that make those hosts
at face value it appears she's keeping
him alive as a kind of torture to show
him what she's gonna do to humanity but
i also wonder if there's another motive
here she also injects him with something
which is supposed to put him to sleep
when this huge gust of smoke envelops
him i wonder if she has the ability to
keep him alive for as long as she wants
in some form of cryogenic freezing
similar to what sorak had done to his
brother in season three this way the
real william could theoretically live
into the far far future depending on how
long he's kept in this stasis may even
caleb's arrival in temperance is
juxtaposed with william opening the park
which now has the full support of the
government and we're left with a pretty
open ending as to what's to come nothing
too major to reveal in this episode it
seems like this is all building up
towards something but what do you think
i want to hear your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching everyone please be sure to
like and subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at think story yt until next
time remember
she wasn't like any woman i've listened
you